you know what's awkward in college i
almost failed public speaking
and now i make a living as a public
speaker
in this video i'm going to share the
lesson that i learned from almost
failing public speaking so that you can
steal that lesson
and apply it to your own conversations
so that you
aren't you don't come across as awkward
and
ideally you don't feel awkward as well
um because nobody needs that let's get
into it
[Music]
so fast forward a bit after dr baku's
public speaking class that i almost
failed i was invited to give a tedx talk
and
in the first 30 seconds of that ted talk
and the
two minutes preceding that ted talk i
would say i was the most nervous i've
ever been in my entire life
choicefully there's been other times
where i felt like my life was at risk or
something and i've been really nervous
but i put myself in that position and
was really really nervous
and the lesson that i learned from
almost failing public speaking and on
how to manage my own nerves
in uh speaking has made me a way more
comfortable
less awkward conversationalists i think
stephen is that true that's true all
right
so uh in college i was giving a speech
and i the reason i almost failed the
class is i tend to talk like this with
my hands and it's just the way that i
speak it's who i
am i can't actually help it i'm not
trying to do it necessarily
but dr baku thought that i needed to use
my hands as batons to direct the
audience's attention
and i thought that was stupid and i
refused to
put myself into this baton mode
and i didn't do well in the class
but i didn't fail and the lesson that i
learned from the fact that
a few years after that was invited to
give a tedx talk and now make my living
as a professional speaker is
if you don't want to be an awkward
period but if you don't want to be an
awkward in conversation
let go of any need you have to be
someone that you're not
right i could have tried to do the
batons but it wouldn't have been
remotely authentic
and every second that i'm not being uh
myself or authentic and this applies in
these videos too when i
make all these videos for for this
channel to share and how to make
engagement and connection easy for me i
if i'm not being totally myself
in the video i don't think it resonates
as well
i think that we value people who are
just transparent that feel like
actual human beings and don't feel like
they're in presentation mode giving you
right it's there's something that
creates a separation
and what erases awkwardness is a
connection
so if you're able to connect with
somebody ideally you
are being really yourself and so is the
other person
now the tedx talk that i gave that you
can check out in a link up here was on
this idea of taking positive social
risks
and in it i talked about this awkward
bump or this anxious bump that
no matter what type of social
interaction you're in
i'm not going to say 100 but i'm
comfortable saying 99.8 percent
of conversations and interactions and
relationships at some point
have at least a moment of awkwardness to
cross over and once you've crossed over
that
it's like a rite of passage of the
relationship and you get to move on
and really connect deeply and that's out
of the way very few people meet each
other and are just like
ah we get along so well there's never
any uh right it's just
that's that is a fairy tale and so part
of not being awkward in conversation
is recognizing that that awkwardness is
actually your own story
and your own label you can uh re-label
that awkwardness
as a conversation in progress
and as soon as you do that the
conversation becomes
changeable and editable now for me i
told you i was the most nervous i've
ever choicefully been
a few minutes before i gave this tedx
talk which is kind of ironic
that i felt so nervous and awkward
before giving a talk about stepping over
this awkward or anxious bump
and my learning with that was for the
first
for the minutes before and for the first
30 seconds of the talk i was so
focused on this person
i was so focused on how people saw me
was i were they going to like this video
were they going to accept and be okay
with the ideas i was sharing were they
going to disagree were they going to
unfriend me on facebook whatever
we have a desire to be liked
i have met very few people who don't
have a desire to be liked at some level
and so that shows up sometimes when we
feel like we're not being liked that
shows up
as awkwardness and so for me the tool to
not be awkward in a conversation
is to flip your perspective and let go
of yourself and what you look like and
feel like etc
and focus on the other person you will
notice that awkwardness
gets deleted right away i will say one
of my mentors eric tyler wrote a book
called the best advice
so far and really brilliant book and
in one of it's the best advice so far um
and one of the chapters is on this idea
that when you call something out or when
you name
something half the awkwardness leaves it
right away or half the power leaves it
right away
and so if you're worried about being
awkward in conversation and the things i
shared in the last couple minutes such
like aren't enough to make you feel less
awkward i would say
call it out call out whatever it is that
you're experiencing or whatever that's
making it awkward
because typically not always but
typically half the awkwardness
gets erased right in that moment i
happened to have
put together a book with my co-author
will wise
on this entire idea of how to have
meaningful conversations
it's called ask powerful questions
create conversations that matter
and books cost money so you can get a
free excerpt of it below for
zero dollars or amazon i think still
sells books
along with everything else in the world
i'm chad
have an awesome day